c'est vrai c'est vrai jacqueline joubert
mais j'allais pas mais c'est pas parce
que j'ai des facilités d'équitation que
j'ai des facilités des kilos sion des
colis d'élocution que je suis non
membres lions d'ingres mon violon grains
ce moment mon dada c'est la cuisine la
cuisine ça derrière ce n'est pas ce que
l'on mange qui nourrit mais ce que l'on
digère tout le monde le sait et c'est
justement parce que personne n'ignore
pas ce que personne n'y règne ne passe
que tout le monde oublie que j'ai voulu
vous dédié cette vérité des diététique
des vite et éthique de cette vérité
quotidienne et éternelle éternel ya qu
en l'illustrant d'un exemple pour vous
éclairer
il ya qu une bonne façon au fond de
faire le boeuf mouton au fond le boeuf
me torrent le mof ni aux murs entend le
must le d'ailleurs il ya certainement
une erreur dans le mou français riez
vous les italiens des myron donne en
couronne
ils ont raison ils ont raison puisqu'on
dispose de la bonne on dispose la bonne
la bonne viande en en couronne enfin
bref cette recette à l'essence a cessé
hier à celle ci vous voyez tout
s'arrange
elle avoue commencer par consommer tenez
vous consommez je veux dire vous
commencez par émincés la viande savez au
couteau pas à la râpe 6 à 700 grappe à
700 grammes de bon boeuf bouilli de
préférence un morceau que vous avez
choisi vous même chez votre boucher dans
sa partie grassouillette pas du boucher
alors vous débouchez aussi vous faisait
masser aussi j'aime assez et émincer 3
août à neutron cm3 ou crac oignons 3 ou
3 ou crac trois ou sept petits ou savez
ce que vous mettez dans une sauteuse
pour les faire bondir blondir lardons
part d'un blanc dire en compagnie d'un
petit morceau de beurre et si cet oignon
de fond tu te fous du dessus et c'est
toute cette fondue d'oignons que vous
épie cc2s épices et 7 lits
nous et voilà de farine de farine comme
quantité bas il faut une bonne cuillère
y ait une bonne cure ayez de une culture
un fin et de deux passés à trois doigts
ou trois ans ça ne venait pas de
couilles à fulham 1-2 cas n'oubliez pas
de la remuée souvent si vous voulez la
faire sourire roussir pardon puis vous
là des glaces et d'un demi des six
litres de vinaigre feurs et vous la
paire et mon dieu après à n'oublier pas
surtout à j'allais l'oublier moi même la
joute est une pure et une plutôt
exactement une cuillérée de tomates en
purée de tomate enrhumé aux engelures
est et une pincée une seule passer 2h
hyper c'est oublier que c'est pas
compliqué de persil haché
que dire alors une fois cuit votre
oignons par votre oignons votre oignons
à dison vos oignons je ne portais pas
vos oignons bien sûr à ses moignons
d'une même ballard autant garder votre
oignons alors votre oignons puis vous
quittez le boeuf
je veux dire le boeuf vous suivez loi
fait et pendant un quart d'heure n'avait
plus qu'à le regarder cuir alors je vous
cache pas que je serai obligé de
rectifier la fadeur inévitable du boeuf
bougies du boeuf bouilli poivre ou brain
drain brin de branches de thym quoi ou
vin blanc vin blanc vin blanc ou une
miette tout petit verre de coni devant
nous ne recherchons pas de complication
car n'oublions jamais que ce sont les
savons les saveurs dans la déglutition
les saveurs premièrement qui date le fou
qui flatte le goût et deuxièmement
qu'ils suscitent les organes digestifs
savait pas si cette double vertus
digestives qui fait que nous dire autant
nous miro ton je veux dire miro dont le
mot que je cherchais qui fonde se mirent
au temps où miron temps la preuve que
c'est à la cuisine et du soir au matin
que mijote notre destin cqfd servi cqfd
c'est une abréviation que je viens
d'imaginer à l'instant même pour vous
permettre de tout résumé de tout retenir
cqfd condiments et qualité facilité pour
digérer c'est toute la vie
[Musique]